in 2003 the human genome project
finished a monumental scientific
achievement the first complete human
genome map a couple of decades later and
you can get a genetic test done by
spitting in a tube and paying a couple
of hundred dollars but that's not quite
what I'm here to talk about this is
Kubrick one of the most advanced brain
imaging centers in Europe and here
they're not scaring genomes the scamming
connectomes the connectome is a phrase
that was coined several years ago and
it's to really encapsulate the idea of
mapping all the connections in the brain
in one go those connections are formed
by what we call the white matter in the
brain so we know the brain has gray
matter
it also has white matter and these form
these wires we're also really interested
in what we call the microstructure being
able to differentiate between the size
and shapes of cells that may be only a
thousandth of a millimeter across what
this kind of other labels to do is to
get information about differences across
the whole brain in a way that would only
previously be possible postmortem
now I begin to scan myself but alas I
have a bit too much metal in my body oh
don't worry about me or the camera
getting sucked into this though this is
just the simulator that they trained on
there's no actual magnets in there
the real scanner is over there this MRI
scan of the magnetic field gradient
allows you to be sensitive to the motion
of water molecules over a distance of
about a thousandth of a millimeter to
map somebody's complete connectome first
we have to acquire the raw data then we
have to fit it to mathematical models
then we have to reconstruct those
pathways and so we rapidly expand from a
few hundreds of megabytes up to tens of
gigabytes all the hopeful
science-fiction fans out there shouldn't
get too excited in the same way as
copying someone's genome doesn't let you
make an actual copy of them just a baby
that's an identical twin that doesn't
know anything
Scalia Connect Oh doesn't mean that you
can certainly upload someone into a
computer it's kind of like this generate
roadmaps not satellite photos heck of a
road map though I think we're a long way
from bunnell to identify differences and
personality at the present time but
that's not to say we won't be able to do
it in the future
generally people are connected in the
same way but it's subtle differences in
the shapes of the tracks
it does seem to be highly reproducible
if we scan 300 people and then scan one
of those people just one more time you
can easily identify them out of that 300
people essentially any neurological or
psychiatric disease that you can think
of they're all symptoms of malfunction
of the brain and we know that function
of the brain relies on information
transfer from one region to another we
can say things such as there's something
different with the integrity of the
white matter potentially if you can name
a neurological or psychiatric disease
the information that we get from this
scanner is going to be a boon and give
us major new insights if we could bring
the cost of the technology down you
could go in for your connectome scan and
have the personalized treatment tailored
to your specific connect ohmic deficit
right now connecthome scans are
cumbersome and expensive and they take a
long time to process and visualize but
that was true of genome scans just 20
years ago in a decade or two connection
research might unlock just as many
benefits for the world thank you very
much to everyone at Kubrick at carnac
University if you want to know more they
have a YouTube channel you can check out
or there's a link in the description